now thank you for joining us I'm John
langler Monday the Nevada legislative
session gets underway and one major
topic is our nursing shortage already
lawmakers are considering some new ways
to retain and attract talent to our
state Candace Charles explains
it really tried their best to care for
other people's families that are not
even their own Eloise Crystal Mercado
knows this all too well breathe out
during the pandemic three of her
grandparents were fighting for their
lives after getting coveted I could just
see that like it was tough for the
nursing caring for him and for me I
wanted to be able to be a part of that
so she changed careers for Malia teaches
she left the classroom in California to
go back to the classroom here in Nevada
enrolling in the Arizona College of
Nursing Las Vegas the Nevada Health
Association reports the silver state is
short more than 7 500 nurses and time is
of the essence we're on the cusp of
something pretty big a recent study
indicates that by 2023 1 million
registered nurses in the U.S are set to
retire did we need to be able to ebb and
flow across the country to areas of
Crisis Diane McKinnis of the Nevada
nursing association tells me that nna
would like Nevada to enter the enhanced
nursing licensure compact allowing out
of state nurses to help when needed and
making recruiting easier breathe in
accelerate nursing programs like the one
Mercado attends is also a solution Dr
Jill Rankin is the dean at mercado's
college she says she's seen an increase
in enrollment but there's another issue
we do see that nursing education has not
met the demand of the need also without
Educators it's tough for the solution to
fix the problem to be able to help and
be part of that change to be able to
serve other people's families and to
care for them and to be able to provide
the what I would want how my family to
be cared for I'm Candace Charles 8 News
Now
right now the Nevada Hospital
Association says the state needs at
least 4 000 nurses just to meet the
national average